hey guys it's marcus again and welcome
to another hd video and first of all
what i want to cover in this is a nice
little website i found as you might have
already seen in the title this one's
called crystalxp.net so just open any
web browser
and actually i already have it loaded up
here and i will be sure to put the link
in the description but it is crystal
xp.net
um basically what this does is it helps
you customize your computer quite a bit
i remember when i had windows xp
i use this website a lot for my
customization but um
first off when you go to the downloads
tab it says it offers a large gallery of
um wallpapers icons icon sets animations
and brickle packs now what they
specialize in is that whole brico pack
thing
basically what the brico packs are if i
were to click on that tab it's basically
skins that skin the entire windows uh
windows xp experience set your windows
your taskbar your start menu everything
is changed to look like a certain theme
so if we go down here crystal clear i've
never even heard of that one vista
inspirod is a very very popular one for
windows xp users trying to get the
windows xp or windows vista look
another one is longhorn inspirot crystal
xp etc so that's more about brico packs
but what they also offer at
crystalxp.net is a wide variety of
customization features and things that
you can just download to make things
look really sweet
so for example if i wanted to download
um say a little bit of software like
windows expose
i'm going to do another video on this
but basically what you click is either
the title or more info and download i'm
going to click more info on download
and right here it'll say right here you
have the download link and when you
click on it you know it'll obviously
bring up the little window that says you
sure you want to open close or save wait
for it
and it's going to be a dot zip file as
you can see by the url obviously but i'm
going to cancel this because i don't
want to start it yet
but yeah that's basically what it is
it's very simple it takes you to a
direct download link and you get a ton
of customization features and you can
also get rocket dock icons for this at
this particular website as well so i
just thought you guys might be
interested in that pretty cool website
i'll post a link in the description if
you're watching this video in hd it's
going to be below and to the right if
you still haven't watched it in hd yet
it's just going to be directly to the
right of this video
and that is basically it so thanks for
watching that's a quick little tutorial
on how to well basically a quick little
video on
crystalxp.net thanks for watching guys
peace